you're busy with like this amazing
record that I'm very excited but I got
to sing because I only got to hear the
songs you let me hear that I would see
you on so I'm and I got the record and I
just literally you never fail to impress
me with like your voice it's insane like
literally like it's insane how talented
you are like the record is amazing and
you know what I love about is you stick
to country music it sounds like country
music well it's it's what I grew up on
him it's what I love is the music that I
was influenced by I'm a big Linda
Ronstadt fan and you know that stuff has
fiddles and steel guitars all over it
she crushed genres yeah yeah yeah that
was really cool so I'm not a traditional
country singer but I definitely fall in
the country category and I just want to
tell you guys when Kelly come in to sing
on the record I've been asked about this
in every interview I've been doing this
week about the album release I'm like
I'm like what is it about Kelly I'm like
she's not real like she's not normal
like she's just amazing crazy and she
comes in and she just you know I hear
this high strong harmony and I know I'm
not gonna sing it and I'm like Kelly can
you go over and do this for me and it's
just amazing what you bring and I know
you could probably every one you sing
with you make them sound better but I
love our voices together oh my god I
love singing with you yeah let's do more
[Applause]
and I got there and I had no idea that
her husband was gonna be like producing
and I was like and I got in this studio
and I'll tell you I've never been more
nervous about sounding good because I
was like you're there already that was
nerve-wracking enough and then your
husband who's you know Garth freakin
Brooks walks in and he's like
and literally he was producing me I was
peeing my pants I was like this is no
worth but anyway I was trolling my
session to try to get you to work with
him that's totally what he was literally
about to die because I was so nervous
both of you I mean it's just admit
you're just such this power couple and
it's like oh please if you go back and
listen to the enterprise if I don't know
if you remember this at the end we were
there these licks at the end and so we
were kind of doing these answers to each
other and I remember that I had done
something and you went in and then you
did you're like I'm like let me go back
in there like give me another shot and
so I went back in and did it again cuz
it let me go back in there I think but
he's actually really cool I was worried
does he ever crash your girls night does
he does he seems funny he's a little
afraid of that many women together so he
really doesn't like he will but if he is
if he's around he'll open the wine but
he really wants to be gone like he'd
rather be like I think it scares him a
little bit as it should you know okay so
I know that whenever you cook sometimes
you're a fabulous cook she has I've gone
in her house to make stuff and she gives
you wine it's the most amazing
experience but one thing I found out
actually was the fact that when he
cooked sometimes right girls sometimes
okay and he has he's like very like
perfectionist in it right he's losing
pretty good great he's pretty good I
wouldn't say perfectionist he doesn't
follow a recipe he's pretty much like
we'll throw things together that maybe
go together and then he thinks it's
fabulous and takes a picture of it
I call him garthe's Stewart because
[Laughter]
garfish Stewart very price like look I
made the sandwich I could take a picture
of it like that's awesome honey yeah and
you're like meanwhile you're like look
I'm a cooking show and I'm badass but
I'll be like I'll be like can you open
this jar of pickles like well I have my
own cooking show I'm like really
seriously so here's the thing I love the
every girl like tell me why you chose
that's name for your record that's song
like tell me where did every girl come
from the truth is thank you very much
the truth is we you are every girl the
truth is that I went in to make a record
for fun I'm 54 years old I'm a woman my
expectations' of what was gonna happen
with this record we're not super high so
I just was like I just want to make a
record I love and I wasn't thinking
about singles I wasn't thinking about
radio at all should be just what we
should be doing if you want to call
yourself an artist you make art and
that's what you do that's what and then
you figure out what to do with it and
this song was one of the first ones I
heard and I just liked it I liked what
it said it basically that has a line
that says you've got this baby so what
if you don't I love that line because
it's like we're always trying to be so
perfect and it's really nice when we're
told it's okay to not be perfect yeah
and then it just kind of and when my
team heard it they're like this we're
going to radio and this is the song and
I've been more shocked than anybody that
it's getting played on the radio which
it is so I'm like yeah that's what I
love about your record it sounds country
it's what it's supposed to be like and
honestly in this time in country music
like I grew up in the 90s like it's like
listening to music so like there were so
many of y'all there are so many great
like country women and like right now
it's hard just to be a woman to get
played on country music and then you're
saying oh I'm 54 it's hard to do that if
it devry ready guys it's like all these
layers of and I don't understand that
either because people think well maybe
countries it's just behind but in the
90s there were so many female artists oh
my gosh I could name a plethora yeah so
what happened I have this conversation
all the time with all the girls I'm like
all the girls any one country music I'm
like what's happening I think like my
fault I left town I moved to Oklahoma
yeah yeah why did you know I when I
moved to Oklahoma - and married Garthim
we raised the girls and when we came
back I was shocked I was like what has
happened I know I had to do that her
played right and I don't really know the
answer I do know that living in
Nashville now the girls have kind of
banded together and it's been really
cool to see generationally like the
young girls who grew up on she's love
with a boy and then my generation and
then we've got Reba and Loretta
everybody's kind of this girl Club and
the conversation is now being had out
loud and loudly and the end the men in
our industry who support that like like
Garth and Blake and in Luke who've
spoken out about it
that's when change happens so I think
right now everybody's just being really
loud the CMA is this you're going to be
hosted by three women for the first time
in the history
it's just saying it's just saying we're
here we're not going on but let's team
up let's make beautiful music let's make
something happen I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this